[Musique]
c'est l' affaire qui a secoué le monde
des miss cette semaine une prétendante
au titre de miss auvergne 2019 a poussé
un gros coup de gueule sur les réseaux
sociaux amandine bio accuse le comité de
l'avoir écarté du concours à cause de
son poids
le comité régional lui aurait d'abord
envoyé un mail pour lui signifier
qu'elle n'était pas retenue avant de lui
donner les raisons au téléphone par
téléphone on m'a dit que j'étais
beaucoup trop ronde c'est clairement de
la grossophobie tout ça parce que je
fais une taille 42 c'est dégueulasse
mais ce n'est pas marqué dans le contrat
seule la taille rédhibitoire le comité a
également réagi en soulignant qu'il
n'avait pas à se justifier en ce qui
concerne les raisons pour lesquelles les
jeunes femmes sont écartés ou non pour
amandine son éviction à cause de son
poids n'est ni plus ni moins que de la
discrimination et serait donc illégales
alors selon vous la jeune femme at elle
été victime de grosses aux phobies
et amender avec de ce soir bonsoir
alors vous avez 24 ans vous êtes
première dauphine de miss volcan
auvergnat 2019 et vous mesure 1 m 119
et selon vous avez été écarté pour un
problème de poids
alors moi je vous dis comme ça
franchement moi je vous aurez
sélectionné mais intéressant c'est
comment est ce que un sas manifeste
parce qu'effectivement quand on a
progressé je tente dans les sélections
qu'on ait mis sous verre extra
normalement très logiquement on va
concourir pour mes chances oui
effectivement en fait c'est la miss en
fait en question donc mis deux volcans
d'auvergne qui a son ticket d'entrée à
l'élection de miss auvergne et les
dauphines normalement voilà elle passe
elle passe une journée de sélection
enfin tout comme les autres les autres
filles qui viennent qui n'ont pas été
élus d'une élection départementale parce
que peut-être il ya pas deux il n'y a
pas de comité et c'est en fait on se
retrouve tous sur sur une journée de
sélection est là en fait on était en
étaient 14
donc normalement un nombre tout à fait
correct pour l'élection miss haut rhin
comment est ce que parce que c'est
important que les gens comprennent
comment est-ce qu'on matérialise en fait
de peut ne pas vous sélectionné parce
qu'il ya un problème de poids
c'est terrible pour le coup oui car oui
on vous l'a dit voilà visiblement
téléphone oui on a essayé de rouler bon
bout des doigts ça va pas la phrase est
trop grosse ou entièrement en fait on
m'a clairement dit abete est une très
jolie et très jolie tête mais le corps
ne passe pas riva bella c'est
condamnable à ces condamnations et là où
j'ai extrêmement choquant effectivement
peut-être qu'on adapte aux
discriminations c'est que les
sélectionneurs ne sont pas obligées de
légitimer leur choix nerfs qui n'ont pas
de critère a dévoilé heureusement outre
la laisse
non non mais attendez il ya les critères
ils noient objectiver les raisons du
refus
donc c'est terrible parce que ça veut
dire que c'est totalement hypocrite ils
ne prennent pas et vous le dise par oral
comme ça au détour d'une salle et au
téléphone mais
ne légitime pas on sait que c'est ça
parce que vous faites une bye blondie
ils arrivent ils ont dit laissez en 2011
willy disent non mais attendez ils
disent comme ça de manière officieuse il
n'ya pas s'il n'y a pas moyen moi j'ai
essayé une fois il n'y a pas moyen
d'obtenir un critère qui légitime leur
enveloppe
officiant que c'est une honte c'est le
comité miss france faut être donc de
sexe féminin moi ça évidemment est né en
beauté de majorité françaises pas
forcément être nés en france âgés entre
18 et 24 ans est célibataire mesurer au
minimum 1 m 110 et posséder un casier
vierge
point barre c'est bien quoi a priori il
ya partant de ce postulat là
n'apporterait et y compris ceux qui sont
un peu abondants bon prof peut se
présenter dans ce focus vous êtes faux
culs excusez moi je suis désolé c'est un
concours le concours français je suis
désolé il ya des critères vous l'avais
dit il ya des critères de taille
moi j'aurais rêvé de faire miss france
franchement j'aurais rêvé eh ben à
l'époque quand j'étais jeune et plutôt
fraîche
on m'a toujours dit que j'étais trop
petit je ne pouvais pas le faire si
j'avais fait un 42 ou 1,44
j'aurais pas pu le faire non plus donc
il faut pas il faut qu on nous arrête
vous arrêtez moi je dois discuter ont
fait un concours offert un concours on
dit voilà il faut être faut être grande
ferme 110 faut être mince ne faisait pas
plus de temps j'ai pas de problème avec
ça mais ne ne faut pas obéir aux gens
venez présenter vous et après le rendez
vous est trop grosse ce qui fut dit
alors ils sont faux cul aussi mais oui
on va pas les accuser grossophobie pas
si bas c'est toi elles sont plutôt bien
en chair ces défis qui sont bien qu'ils
sont quand même va pas racheter de la
grossophobie sylvie tellier sur france2
d'accord qui est hypocrite je suis
devant l'apple potati wahaha
on a longtemps dit je serais ravi
d'accueillir une miss transgenres autres
et parce que c'est un transgenre c'est
un homme
d'accord c'est passer de sexe masculin
bonjour j'ai dérangé d'accord mais bon
elle a pas précisé donc c'est on peut
considérer que c'est elle parlait de ça
maintenant dans le règlement c'est marc
effectivement de sexe féminin
obligatoirement ok donc à pas pour
enlever la taille
donc en fait elle est prête à changer
les règles quand ça les arrange elle
fait genre dans les médias nous on est
ouvert on est super cool c'est génial
mais en fait elle sait très bien qu'elle
pourra pas le faire de toute manière
dont kader est allé tranquille mais par
contre une jeune femme effectivement qui
fait du 42 où elle peut la prendre parce
qu'elle est belle et pas
et dans les règles les règles n'y a pas
de problème est bien là il ne la
prennent pas donc c'est à l'hypocrite et
c'est leur concours qui sont hypocrites
désolé puisque quelque chose qu'on
n'oublie c'est quand même très très
important c'est qu'il ya une femme sur
deux en france qui fait plus que 42 donc
je suis désolé et alors quand on vous a
dit que c'était on vous a répondu un
concours d'élégance sous-entendu aussi
on fait du 42 e on et plus élégante
moi je si c'est pas de la grossophobie
je ne sais pas ce que c'est aujourd'hui
amandine clairement qu est ce que j'ai
envie de dire au comité miss france qui
sur mon nouveau de regarde d'abord je
vous en avais été mais c'est orthez
parce que c'est oui oui j'en ai été j'en
ai été blessé mais je pense que je suis
pas la seule je pas là ça dans ce cas là
et moi je comprends pas c'est que
pourquoi parce que on vous laisse
participé à une partie du concours puis
on vous retire et juste parce que juste
avant la dernière marche
on vous sort pour une raison ça c'est
terrible et clairement moi aussi je ce
que j'ai pas dit jusqu'à maintenant et
maintenant je le dis c'est qu'on est
venu me chercher au mois de mars
on m'a envoyé un message sur facebook
pour me dire écoute amandine tu as tout
à fait ta place tu viens donc j'ai fait
l'élection au mois de mai 2000 volcans
d'auvergne où j'ai été super bien
accueilli
c était le comité organisateur de
l'élection et c'était c'était c'était
super franchement c'était un magnifique
moment et je pense que j'ai été élue
première dauphine donc je pense que les
gens ils ont ils ont aimé le changement
ils ont aimé mais ce côté
finalement ben finalement week et
j'écris entre guillemets peut-être cassé
les codes et si fait que ça a plu aux
gens sauf que c'est l'occasion de me
trompe mais la dernière miss france elle
est bien un peu dans mon rap dans mon
coin quand même on est là pas dans mon
temps mais elle est bien en forme mais
c'est déjà bien mais le plus de fait du
poids faire de est-ce que vous auriez
était prête à perdre du poids pour
participer jusqu'au bout aux conceptions
je pose la question c'est franchement
changé une personne alors qu'elle est
très bien dans son temps c'est dans ses
baskets très bien dans sa tête et dans
son corps
non en fait n'ont en revanche pas tandis
que vous accusez le comité vous comptez
faire quoi j'attends rien du tout moi
j'ai 18 je raconte mon histoire en fait
parce que comme je disais je suis pas la
seule
et je suis peut-être pas forcément la
première non effectivement mais je suis
l'une des premières à ouvrir ma bouche
en fait et etc etc beaucoup de personnes
qui souffrent de ça moi j'ai 24 ans je
pense que j'ai un minimum
quand même la tête sur les épaules et
j'ai un petit peu de recul sur les
choses ça aurait été une gamine de 18
ans on lui dit tu es très belle mais
était trop grosse et vous imaginez les
conséquences dramatiques que ce jugement
c'est incroyable qu'on vous ait dit ça
comme ça aussi
oui ils viennent il y ait des groupes en
mars ils te font participer à ça est ce
que le comité des gens du comité t'on
demandé de maigrir pour pouvoir les gens
qui souffrent sans avoir à écrire dans
le comité à ce qu'ils sont venus
chercher en mars par rapport à ton
visage par mois oui en fait le truc
c'est que j'ai déjà participé il ya
trois ans il ya quelques uns en erreur
et effectivement moi je faisais toujours
ma taille 42 parce que c'était la taille
que j'ai toujours fait toute ma vie du
moins quand j'ai atteint la dure l'âge
d'être une femme
et du coup c'est là où moi j'ai
clairement dit je fais une taille 42
donc je ne sais pas si ça pas dans les
critères de miss monde parce que moi
même je ne savais même pas ce qu'il y
avait comme critère un niveau du pont au
niveau de la taille du tour de taille
etc
et c'est là où on m'a dit bon écoute
essayer de faire ton possible pour
entrer dans une taille 38 40
et le truc c'est que moi entre
guillemets voilà les désarmer auparavant
j'étais peut-être qu'une amie j'étais
j'avais peut-être moins confiance en moi
et c'est donc effectivement oui j'ai
perdu un petit peu mais t'es pas autant
que ce qu'ils attendaient moi j'avais
pas envie de perdre 46 lots pourront
pendant quatre mois sans cesse qui n'est
pas la femme vous avez défilé en maillot
de bain donc j'avais fait toutes les
étapes classiques licencié au même
opposé à vous aucun problème non du tout
moi je suis bien comme je suis je veux
dire j'ai dit tout rien à envier bon
alors vous a fait aucune remarque non
tiens et pitt on tienne pépite on va la
faire maigrir on tienne pépite parce
qu'elle est jolie comme tout sauf
qu'elle n'a pas envie de maigrir et
qu'elle est bien dans sa peau qu'il faut
40 comme ça même si c'est vrai c'est
venir n'ont même pas c'est pire qu'au
bout d'un mètre en qu'ils me le disent
eux-mêmes parce que c'est très hypocrite
ils se disent eux mêmes ils sont piégés
par leurs propres choix à la rive nord
et donc ils boycottent mademoiselle mais
d'une manière mais c est monté pourquoi
vous portez pas plainte pour
discrimination non non bien nous on aime
bien attiser un peu les
vous direz c'est bien maintenant
franchement ça nous arrange voilà voilà
voilà le dossier
surtout que dans la vie on croise plus
souvent déjeuner comme amandiers lewis
des minces comme on voit dans des
missions qu'on a fait c'est vitaly ont
écouté il ya eu il faut ce qu'il faut
moi je suis comme ça je trouve ça
bizarre quand même qu'on ait laissé une
bosse qui me scandalise -6 et des règles
qu'on vous ait dit non allez vite vous
auriez des règles mais qu'on vous aider
c'est croire défilé avançait pas au
final vous dire vous êtes vous êtes trop
excusez moi c'est inacceptable
je vous le dis ça m'a mis en colère 1
voilà ben non mais qui ne s'étaient pas
[Rires]
donc je vous ai dit si vous le regardez
je vous lance un appel venez nous
répondre avec cyril je sais pas quand
une prochaine avec moi comme vous voulez
mais honnêtement ce que vous avez fait
vivre à amandine elle faire croire le la
faire rêver à faire avancer pour au
final là vous l'avez son humour
téléphone la peña s'il vous plaît les
murs ça ne se met vite sévices
européenne à l'eau va voir que c'est mal
au dos mais par l'air allô allô allô ya
pas de chrono il dit alors quand même
première ce deuxième sonnerie n'a pas de
chance avec le téléphone à des missions
[Applaudissements]
amandine croyez moi on va sur cette
affaire et et on va pas en rester là
parce que c'est pas normal